[Applaudissements]
pas possible d'être aussi faire c'est
très simple vous allez taper tous les
deux à entrer en couple dans la machine
ici c'est très simple ok on additionnera
vos scores le plus gros score affrontera
arsène y voilà d'accord si vous battez
arsène à 2 vous aurez un magnifique
cadeau jal a fait 14 satov plus combien
214 pour le brute du groupe
mathieu il est pas mal aujourd'hui
largement devant rama yade s'ignorent
247 6 ans va nous faire 646 ses 146 846
alesi le groupe c a pour l'instant c'est
jean michel et gérald
[Applaudissements]
ce pas possible d'être schipper terme et
se remet et ça c'est pas possible
puissance est non vous êtes éliminés
c'est toujours jean michel et gérald
caillat à 896 8 146 merci pas mal ça
suffira pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ouais c'est bon c'est mort c'est perdu
c'est beau c'est beau c'est beau c'est
pas tout à fait mûr carottes verra pas
les vagues assez 845 allait bien elle
est moins important
certes a pas tenu compte aujourd'hui
donne tout cinq champions
spécial
il vous gagnez le nouveau show
redemption micromania c'est pour nous et
on apprend que c'est pour vous monsieur
ron johnson de ses actifs
[Musique]